oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un conte moi quand on était au pays de
jumilhac le grand yaka m'ordonnait des
travaux plus ni moins je le pouvais en
amendant je suis désigné pour faire le
ménage avec ses balles et je dois
ramasser poussière et la mettre dans son
baquet pour la montrer aux grands yade a
fait famille gaulle ou comme probable je
vais commencer par me reposer il faut
toujours se reposer avant de travailler
huit bateaux passent de 8 ans si le
brouillard nous voyez istres est content
un plus petit bateau
on va jouer aux régates
[Musique]
jeter nos ventes avec le ballet annaba
le petit bateau titus je viens
surveiller ton travail j'avance et mon
cas tu vois c'est une méthode
personnelle et ça a l'air à busan
lemétayer moka toi tu as dit le ballet
et l'air qu'il déplaçait à vanter les
bateaux à messieurs passion s'appelle
derrière un bateau mais ce n'est qu'un
rêve le premier à la colonne de fonds a
gagné c'était capable de mosca ne
revient pas je lui ai dit va surveiller
le travail de têtu s'est relevé
immédiatement mais il ne revient pas
jusqu'à mosca mais où est il passé
moscou s'est si bien ici il y passa ses
mosquées et ramène le tu as compris si
il est bien basé ici je te donne une
minute pour amener mosca de casser mon
bateau qui va gagner
institut g show jeu russe dépenses toi
bien sinon tu vas noyer le bateau et ça
y est très grave
titus mon bateau a rattrapé le tuer a
dit ceci
qu'est ce que tu fais ici je parie que
c'est le grand iata qui t'envoient ils
pillent a ordonné de me ramener ici si
tu n'as pas envie de jouer avec nous
qu'ils s'initient pas cherché à bâle et
titus va faire un bateau pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ea bateau porte et mathieu est ternie
tout ne fait avancer en faisant de l'air
avec ton balèti à trois bateaux étaient
encore plus rigolo je suis un homme sur
idées capables et ceux ci qui ne
viennent pas que le talent cela va me
chercher mosquée et ceux ci et plus vite
que ça a c'est tout ce que tu viendrais
avec nous pas prendre un ballet s'est
offert un bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de plus en plus forte la bataille navale
habite là était de nous rattraper il
un émoi nécessaire je me disais tu sais
moi les blagues haka ait pu marquer et
on voit qu est-ce qui commande ici et
ils ont rempli le coup de bâton eason
10000 20000 centre ville ces quelques
1000 coups de bâton j'étais dépassé boko
ses barreaux d'un code qui me gêne
relève de la garde mon sport
une visite ou là où la sauve qui peut
c'est le grand yaka par la barbe de mes
ancêtres mais qu'est ce que c'est que
sial grande yaka
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter mes
petits bateaux du patou de mon palais
mais à l'horizon que moi mais
certainement grand yaka tout six bateaux
sont les vôtres
c'est bien c'est bien alors je suis le
grand yaka des petits bateaux voulez
vous jouer avec eux et c'est j'étais
très rapide dans wii a essayé de bien
sérieux site us ils bossent et qui
quitte je te nomme amiral deuxième à
dire est trop petit bateau le grand gala
a balayé tout emballé et après tu
noteras
[Applaudissements]
on